[Music]
on November 18 1992 nan ABC at a p.m.
Eastern for America's Funniest Videos
with Bob Saget then at 8:30 it's
America's funniest people with Dave
Coulier then at 9:00 gather the kids for
part 1 of the miniseries about the clown
that will eat your children in twos DNA
settle in for a night up who's the boss
followed by head of the class and at
9:00 it's part two of the mini series
about the clown that will eat your
children it move over Jared Leto because
it's time to bow down to the real king
of Murder clowns Tim Curry a serial
killing demon clown from the Bronx who
due to network censorship guidelines
expresses his evil through bad teeth and
mild YouTube pranks he's basically Logan
Paul in clown face but even more
horrifying is this vampire clowns true
form of flood lamp
a spooky flood man who says Stephen King
doesn't know how to write an ending
return to the 90s version of what the
movies 80s were the 50s a time when cops
were Irish the bullies were murderers
and the fat kids were skinny and meet
the losers Club no really if you're
under 30 meet these people for the first
time in your life John Ritter the guy
from Night Court
the original Lana Lang the debt from
Sister Sister and these guys but don't
forget their childhood counterparts guy
from Seaquest whoa said green and
everyone else well come on Ted Danson
wasn't available couldn't book a young
NPH Pinchot Bakula Alf after all the
clown on kid stuff you actually remember
strap in for a second half that's so
forgettable even the main characters
forgot about it remember much of it at
all I can't remember much of anything
and when I try it kind of clouds over
where the less interesting adult version
of the losers Club spends most of the
time wishing they weren't there eating
Chinese food staring off into space
[ __ ] around on a bike and finally
facing off against a dumb spider who
lives in a hobbit hole so get psyched
for it chapter two in theaters now well
good luck Bill Hader so revisit a noble
effort that was doomed from the start
with the super low-budget the
constraints of TV censors and aspect
ratios and three hours to tell a
thousand-page story just stop before you
get started next time okay if you can't
afford the cosmic turtle or even a
decent cave spider don't adapt it or the
Dark Tower or the stand or L'Engle ears
or really anything Stephen King
[Applause]
story Tim scurry fray Court Dairy Queen
Molly Molly Molly Molly Molly morning
sevens company flashback phase
[Music]
face touchin
group hug in
no joke here just a moment to appreciate
how good of an actor jonathan brandis
was I wanna kill it scotch I present to
you this year's winner of the very
prestigious architect award for
architecting when I drink champagne I
always bring champagne back tonight and
coming soon be on his trailer at 4:00
whatever this movie is as of this
writing rich is still knocking him dead
he's got a part in a movie
[Music]
Darry stories to tell in the dark
I don't see what the big deal is this
happens almost every time I get my Panda
Express on put my money on the giant
monkey when you bring me out can you
introduce me as Joker eat your heart out
Bob Ross help I fell and I can't get up
gta3 Dora d30 today Dora the Explorer